This video is brought to you by Scribd
get 30 days for free by clicking the link
in the description below.
Punch Aveo was one of the most divisive
figures in history to millions.
He was the Mexican or Robin Hood,
but to others he was a ruthless
terrorist who kills without conscience.
What is without a doubt is that he rose
from humble beginnings to become one of
the most famous Mexicans in history
playing a vital role in the decades that
shaped modern Mexico.
In this week's biographics,
we discover the real story of Pancho via,
there's a lot of mystery surrounding the
early life of the man who became Pancho
via most historians believe that
he was born on the 5th of June,
1878 in the tiny village of Rancho
Delacroix Tada in the state of Durango and
Mexico. His birth name was Jose
Dora, Teo Aramco Aramco gala.
When he was a few years old,
his father I boost in Aramco died.
This meant that authority,
Teo,
the oldest of five children have
to start working on the Hacienda,
getting up at three
o'clock in the morning.
He had to walk for 10 miles
to start work at five.
His work consisted of planting
corn and running errands via laser.
Claims that he never attended a
day of school and his entire life.
When not working,
you'd like to play cards and it was
often getting into fights with his peers.
During his teen.
He held a number of odd jobs including
and mule Skinner brick layer runs and
butch up. Then at the age of 16
you moved to Chihuahua for work.
The story goes that two years later he
returned to his hometown in order to hunt
down a man named or Gustin Lopez and
a greater who had raped his sister.
He apparently found the
rapist and kills him.
This episode is said to have
set him on his life of crime.
He fled to the Sierra Madre Mountains
and joined a group of bandits.
Changing his name to puncture via the
bands had soup numbers between 40 and 50
man rated the ranches of the wealthy
in order to steal castle and horses.
They lived in the mountains and
they train. Does guerrilla fighters,
their reputation as fighters against
the system established them as freedom
fighters in the minds of the poor who
gave them shelter and warn them when the
local police,
when we begin in 1902 via was captured
by the police according to the practice
of the times,
he was inducted into the federal army.
He spent several months in the army
and then dessert is heading back to the
hills to rejoin his gang. Around this
time, he actually kills an army officer,
which made him one of the most
wanted men in northern Mexico.
A reward of 10,000 pesos was placed on
his hat pantry became the leader of his
band Dyk group and it's continued to
lead increasingly violent raids upon the
wealthy.
Legend says that he would risk capture
by openly walking through the streets of
shower to distribute money to the poor.
In so doing,
he won the loyalty of the people who
helps protect them from the authorities.
In 1910 Mexico's seemed to be a
model of democratic stability.
Porfirio Diaz had the president for 30
years and the country was celebrating a
hundred years of independence,
but Diaz rules with an iron fist and
the elections that were held every four
years, they were just a facade. In
order to appease foreign governments.
90% of people in Mexico lived in poverty
since 1906 there had been a number of
worker rebellions against the conditions
that they were forced to exist under.
Each one had been forcibly
put down by the Diaz regime.
A number of intellectuals began
writing against this regime,
including a man named Francisco Madero.
He decided to run for president in
1910 what his campaign began to gather
momentum. However, President Diaz had
Mindera arrested and thrown in prison.
The mock election went ahead and Diaz
was reelected for the seventh time,
but Arrow managed to escape from prison
and he fled to the United States.
From that, he began planning
for the revolution. Meanwhile,
down in Chihuahua pantry via had
established a kind of reputation as this
Mexican Robin Hood figure,
a champion of the underprivileged,
but he was also known to be a wild man.
He was a ruthless killer who would
shed blood with utter impunity seeking
respectability.
He met with a supporter of Francisco
Madeira by the name of Abraham Gonzalez by
aligning himself with Madeira.
Gonzalez told Pancho that he would be
able to reinvent himself as a legitimate
man of the people. They, uh,
agreed GNC through the support of his
bandage group behind this revolutionary
cause.
By now,
panacea developed a strong hatred for
the Diaz regime along with the landowners
and the police who had been
hunting him for more than a decade.
He and his men brought skills
to the revolution records
that had been hones over
years of rating, fighting and
debating the authorities in battle.
Pancho fought like a man possessed. And
now that he added an established cause,
he was even more ferocious.
He also proved himself to be
a master of military tactics,
brilliantly marshaling his small band
against much larger governmental forces on
one occasion of the battle
of Escobar's pantry.
But hat's upon planted sticks and it'll
just a full of the opposition into
thinking that he had a much larger
army than he actually did buy.
The beginning of 1911 though that me,
it had grown to 400 people and it was
racking up to slice of victories over the
federal army.
In early 1911 there was a challenge to
the revolutionary leadership of Madeira
from the ultra radical Mexican liberal
party to put down the challenge,
but they wrote turns,
a Pancho who moved in and
arrested the leaders of the Party,
the grateful Madeira rewarded via by
making him a kernel of his revolutionary
army.
In May,
1911 zero is 3000 strong force with
villa at the forefront laid siege to the
border city of Sia. Dot. Horace,
the town was gutted by 500 federal troops
along with 300 civilian auxiliaries
and local police.
The fighting went on for two days and at
the end the federal police surrendered
on May the 25th with his armies being
defeated and public opinion unanimously
against him.
President DNS resigns and fled into exile.
A free and fair election was housing,
which Francisco Madero was
elected presidents, Madeira.
He signed the Treaty of [inaudible] by
which the federal law me would remain in
place. He therefore disbanded the
rebel. Armenians ordered to returns.
They're pretty wild lives,
but Arrow allowed the structure of the
DNS government to remain to Banjo via
this was a fatal error. Bands, he let
his feelings be known. He told Maduro,
you have destroyed the revolution.
It's simple.
This bunch of Dandies of made a fool of
you and this will eventually cost us on
next,
including yours.
Yeah,
VM and his fellow revolutionaries were
also incense that Madeira refuse to
distribute,
sees hacienda land to veterans of the
struggle is payments for the services they
rendered via became increasingly
critical of Madeira is actions,
especially his putting a former
supporter of deposed president Dan says,
minister of war.
Even more outspoken was a
fellow revolutionary leader
by the name of Pascoe al
or Roscoe and March of 1912 or Roscoe
led a rebellion against the new regime.
The Dero called on Via to put it down,
just like being a judge,
devolving Orozco to join the revolts
panel showed that his army of 400 in
conjunction with federal forces in a
series of decisive victories that crushed
the rebellion following
the victory against a row.
Vias bans joins up with federal militia
in the city of tare on in the state of
Quito. The federal commands a General
Victoria on a request out to tested via,
he was initially welcoming
though showering him with
praise and awarding him an
honorary general ship,
but the pleasantries they didn't last
long with quieter accusing pound show of
stealing a horse with his honor in
question via responded by slapping the
general.
This was the pretext that quota was off
to NZ promptly hand via arrested and
charged with insubordination and
execution by firing squad was ordered.
Word of this affair reached President
of Madeira who telegraph clatter and
ordered him to not execute via but to
keep him as a prisoner via was sent.
Do you bet on prison in Mexico City
while incarcerated that he runs a region
right under the guidance of
a fellow prisoner. In June,
he was transferred to
a prison in Santiago.
Six months later though he escaped jumping
on board a train bound for the United
States. On January the second
1913 he arrived in El Paso, Texas,
while in prison, penetrate learns
of a plant coup against Madero. Hey,
I attempted to get a warning
message through to the president,
but it didn't arrive in time.
On February the 22nd 1913 Dario was gunned
down on the orders of general quarter.
The man who had come so close to executing
via just a year earlier question now
installed himself as the new president
of Mexico via was incensed that the
series of events,
even though he had become disillusioned
with his actions upon gaining power,
he still viewed Madeira as the apostle
of democracy and just personal role
model.
Now the Cueto his personal enemy was in,
he knew that he had to return to Mexico.
He indeed felt that the
mantle of completing the
dream of democracy the Madeira
had instilled in him was now
upon his shoulders. Okay,
so now just before we get into vias,
really brutal phase of life,
it's time for me to quickly
tell you about scripts.
Script provides you with a huge library
of books, audio books, magazines,
and other reading material.
They allow you access to an unlimited
number of these every month.
I actually had a membership to squibs
before they even came on board as a
sponsor for this show.
As I made a covenant to read
more in 2019 specifically,
I said that I wanted to finish
20 nonfiction books this year.
So script with that unlimited
plan is perfect for my goal. Also,
I'm reading more magazines
time Macworld Inc.
It's incredible what you can get
for any $8 and 99 cents a month.
I don't really know how they do it for
any $8 and 99 cents a month because I
certainly feel that books
are more expensive than that
audio book certainly are.
I even think some magazines probably
more expensive than $8 a month,
so I said how they do it,
but it's a good deal. Now,
a book that was essential in creating
this video was the mega in depth of the
life and times of Pancho villa and you
can grab that on the script if you want
more or personally, I've been
reading a book called the innovators,
which is entirely unrelated to this video,
but it's actually amazing and I
couldn't not bring it up. Like I said,
I'm trying to read 20 books
and this is one of them.
It's all about people who created the
Internet and computers, the innovators.
You can probably see where the
title comes from. Like I say,
it's not related at all.
I just couldn't not mention it.
You can read that book
or the Pantry Veo one.
You can find a link to do that below,
through that link.
You get 30 days for free and like I said,
you can get any book your wines,
just why not and thanks for script for
sponsoring this video and let's get back
into it.
Except for the wealthy businessmen who
were sort of relieved by this return to
order the vast majority viewed
quarter as a jackal who had stolen the
presidency. In March of 1913
Pancho via returns in Mexico,
intense on avenging the murder of
Madeira and relieving his country of the
tyranny of quieter.
He later recalled that night I had eight
men with me and we had no definite plan,
but I decided to make for my old haunts
in the Sierra Madre mountains where I
knew I could find men to follow me.
We had one sack of flour,
two small packages of coffee and some
salts. That's was all our food supply.
Of course, we were all well armed, but
had little ammunition via small bands,
began making lightning raids upon the
federal forces that were garrison did
northern Mexican towns and forts.
Slowly they were able to accumulate
the arms and supplies that they needed
within a week. Vias, bans, it's
groans or more than a hundred men.
And within three months it had morphed
into a legitimate army of 18,000 troops
in battle. The uh, proved to be
ruthless is standard policy was to kill.
Prisoners are lucky if you would only be
spared by the intervention of his left
hand. It's in contrast to this
brutal side of his nature.
They Pancho who had a strong
social conscience for two months.
In 1913 he held the position
of governor of Chihuahua.
He expropriated lands from the
wealthy to distribute to the poor,
opened at several schools and enacted
laws to protect widows and orphans.
On Christmas Day 1913,
he gathered the poor of Gor together
and gave them each 15 pesos.
They subtractions. He became the hero
and the savior of the underclass.
By 1914 they had control over
the northern parts of Mexico.
I'm thinking over the governorship to
his left tenancy began the march south to
Mexico City. You are quiet or sat in
the presidential chat as he swept,
Southie conquered
everything in his weight,
gaining a reputation as the center
of the north. By June, his arm,
he had grown to 50,000 most of whom
were riding on horseback by now.
It was a fully fledged army with mobile
hospitals and recruits from other
countries including the United States.
At the head of this,
the largest revolutionary army and the
history of the Americas stood Pancho via
Lido with great charisma who at the
same time as the respect and fear rivers
Madden and developed a military strategy
that proved enormously successful day
and night.
He would pour a continuous
frontal assaults against
the enemy lines supported by
cavalry troops.
The attacks were continually ruling with
troops of the France being replaced by
those behind this gave the defenders
and no time to rest resulting in them
almost always being overwhelmed by
this sustained form of attack via also
established offices within his army is
similar to governmental departments.
He had an office of foreign affairs who
were particularly focused on reaching
out to President Woodrow Wilson for USAID.
His financial committee made contact with
wealthy landowners to assure them that
they would not be mistreated
once a victory was achieved.
The United States provided aid
to the revolutionary cause.
Three around about means
via sold livestock and other
products to the u s which
provided the funds with which to
purchase American weapons and ammunition.
It was this flow of weaponry.
This enabled the rebel army to match up
to the federal forces in recognition of
the aid being received from north of
the border via ensured that no American
property was confiscated.
Positive Press and the American media
resulted with the Washington Times
reporting in January of
1914 via is carrying on a
campaign of modern and humane
wharf APP. The media sort of fell
in love with via with one editor.
Writing Vr is without the possibility
of any doubt the greatest leader Mexico
has ever had.
His method of fighting is astonishing.
Like Napoleon's via instituted some
telling innovations in Mexican warfare.
He was the first to leave the women and
children behind and forced the pace of
his army with raids marching
far away from his face.
He would abandon his supply trains and
had far out in search of the enemy.
He was also the first
stage of nighttime attacks,
which became especially
devastating to the enemy.
In the spring of 1914 the two
key cities of Toryonn and Zach,
a k test were taken.
These victories brought the regime to its
knees with quite a fleeing into exile.
On July the 14th,
1914,
the federal army collapsed to
leaving the revolutionary step,
fill the vacuum into the presidency.
Now stabbed Veneziano,
Carranza raw former Hacienda Rhona who
brought his forces into Mexico City.
I had a via, yet it was penetrating the,
uh, who was the hero of the revolution.
Wherever he went,
people would yell out via
via.
And his fellow revolutionary leader is a
potter joined forces to Alice Carranza,
who they had never intended to take
the helm on December the sixth, 1914,
the road to the head of 50,000 men
along sides apart or with his 15,000.
By then grounds,
a hood is naturally flat.
The capital [inaudible] was now at the
height of its power wearing a navy blue
suit and to cap with the Eagle
of the Mexican flag on us.
He rode through the city as the masses
turned out to shower him with praise.
He went to the presidential palace
and sat on the presidential chair,
but only long enough to
have his picture taken.
He never served as the
president of Mexico,
although he could have easily
won an election. At that time,
a council between the various fighting
factions failed to bring a consensus and
via continue to lead his army
against the pockets of rebellion.
Alvaro Obregon was a supporter of Carranza
who won a series of decisive battles
against vias.
Army Pancho was outsmarted by Abra
gone and many of his men were killed.
He was forced to retreat to his base and
the northern Sierra Maestra mountains.
In a few months if fierce fighting the
invincible Ami that had marched into
Mexico City had been reduced to a
ragtag mob of just a few hundred men.
The change now came over
Pancho via his violent streak.
It was fully unleashed in
San Pedro de la quaver.
He brought all of the men in town into
the middle of the town and killed them
all personally shooting the local priest
in the hat. Then in Santa Isabella,
he shot several American minors.
The Americans,
they now distance themselves from via.
Recognize the re-instituted
Cameron's and government.
At around four in the morning on March
the ninth of 1916 via the incense,
the President Wilson had legitimize the
Koran's and government let a force of
100 men across the border into
the town of Columbus, New Mexico.
They're tacked the town of 600
inhabitants from four directions using
indiscriminately as well as the looting
and burning buildings via however had
chosen the wrong town.
The 13th us cavalry was stationed there
with four machine guns and 400 highly
trained soldiers.
The majority of his men were killed.
The bus via managed to get away, leaving
a trail of destruction in its wake.
The American response to the unprovoked
Columbus attack was an overwhelming at
10,000 troops being sent on trains south
of the border with the single objective
of capturing Poncho via the head of the
American forces was John Passion that
his troops along with Apache Indian scouts
350 miles across the border and such
a via into every village that he weds
Pershing would yell out where his Poncho
via every time though the locals would
provide him with false information.
On several occasions,
portions of Pershing's army skirmished
with via and his tiny bands.
On one occasion,
Pancho was shot in the leg in April.
The American newspapers actually reported
that he had died as a result of the
leg being infected.
The reality though was the pantry was
still very much alive though badly wounded
and hiding out in a cave in the Sierra
Madre is Pershing's expedition in managed
to capture weaponry and horses,
but it failed in its objective of
bringing pantry with the Americans having
withdrawn via reverted to
his gorilla fighting ways.
He's still that the support of the
people and was determined to continue
fighting against horrendous regime.
Then in 1920 with another coup in the
offing president's Carranza was killed as
he fled to the Gulf of Mexico
with the national treasure VM.
Saw this turn of events is his opportunity
to come to a peace settlement with a
new regime he rode for 13 days to a city
where he telegraph the new president
Adolfo Dlo Cata requesting an amnesty.
Quite agreed grateful that the threat
of a via overthrow was nullified
via was given a 25,000
acre farm in Canada tear.
He brought 200 of his men with him who
immediately got to work on improving the
rundown property in a
short amount of time.
This area was tend to do a communist had
a school and it grew wheat and corn and
bean crops.
They were able to support the large
community via got up each day to supervise
the work and spend time
in the school house.
Peep hardly bevel left the farm because
he was fearful of being assassinated.
On the morning of July the 20th
1923 via did leaf his ranch.
He went to parral to visit one of his
wives and to withdraw money to pay his
work. It's as, as dodge
vehicle was driving through
eight deserted part of town,
dozens of snipers opened up filling
the car with more than 40 bullet holes.
Nine of these bullets, they
entered pantry fee. His body,
his death was instantaneous. Yet even
in death, Viet did not find peace.
Three years after his burial and
parral whose tomb was ransacked,
the corpse was removed with
the head being cut off.
Souvenir hunters also took pieces
of the coffin and some of his bones.
In 2010 the Wall Street Journal reported
that his right index finger was being
offered at a pawn shop in El Paso.
The asking price $9,500 so I really
hope you found that video. Interesting.
If you did, please do give us a thumbs
up below and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos just like
this several times a week. Also,
check out our fantastic sponsors script.
There's a link to them in the
description below, and as always,
thank you for watching.